A new Fordham Institute study reported
that 28% of teachers in traditional
district schools use personal leave and
sick days
to miss more than two weeks of school
each year. And anyone who's spent any time
in school knows that little gets done
when substitutes are in charge. Teachers
unions could have acknowledged the
problem and pledged to tackle it. Instead
they offered a litany of excuses! One
union leader said the study was
"motivated by an anti-student agenda".
Another termed it "ideological propaganda".
The president of the nation's largest
teachers union said it was "misguided to
think that teachers are missing too much
time". Now let's be fair: teaching has its
upsides, but it's a tough profession.
Teachers are on their feet for hours at
a stretch. If they feel dizzy or down,
they can't just take a long lunch or
knock off early. Teachers can't even go
to the bathroom when they want!
Acknowledging all of that is absolutely
in order, yet it will be hard for
teachers to earn the professional esteem
they seek until those who claim to speak
for their profession start to grow up.
To learn more about my take on the role of
teachers unions, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.